[Music]
there were once two sisters
the older sister walked ahead of the
younger one
so the younger one always knew where to
go
how are you doing
because your grandma and i have been a
little worried about you my sister is
dead
there's no more music in me
no more dreams in me
i've lost the one person on earth who
understood me
how is school bad as expected he's a new
boy in honor band
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
you must be lennon walker
toby stop by go keep him company make
him feel welcome he is not interested in
talking to me
she was the love of his life
[Music]
no one at school gets it
i don't think it's possible to get it
unless you're in it like we are and
you believe in science from the beyond i
believe in everything cause you've got
me yes
by the way
the heart breaks
music escapes
that's how it gets out
if the tide takes california
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm so glad i got joe fontaine
toby shaw
i know i shouldn't have come i just miss
her so much
we're here
without her
[Music]
okay
we're gonna be okay
[Music]
what's going on with you
i'm so grief in love
i don't think we get one without the
other
with joe i feel so very alive
but when i'm with toby
there is someone with me in my grief
i want to live like my sister did
daring
and spirit
and so
much joy
[Music]
[Music]